foreign
comes from Alan in Pennsylvania some
legislators in my state are introducing
a bill to do a study on universal basic
income at this point it's just a
proposal to do a study but I was curious
what your thoughts are on the government
providing low-income people with a
monthly stipend I know other parts of
the world have introduced forms of it to
varying degrees of success
uh okay I'm not a fan of any type of
universal basic income for a variety of
reasons I'm gonna try to keep this short
uh first and foremost it does not create
incentive it does not allow someone to
see the value of showing up and putting
in some work and we know from human
behavior and we saw this in the United
States it's why we're in the
inflationary period that we're in
when we give out more money and
unemployment benefits were increased and
extended people spent the money people
don't save the money people need Dignity
of work to get up go do something get
paid and watch themselves continue to
make progress and the argument for
people that are pro stipend and I'm
seeing this all over the place in the
United States being tested in multiple
cities right now and it is a social
entitlement an entitlement if you look
at the word in the dictionary unless you
do it on your own it does not create
incentive it actually de-incentivizes
people and they end up misusing it so I
for that reason I'm not a fan of it at
all it's also a slippery slope to a
universal income across the board which
we see in socialistic countries like
Venezuela Cuba and more go do your
homework on how that has worked out yeah
generally speaking if you study history
communism has failed
for the little man to get ahead
capitalism
and its current form today
is not perfect but it is by far in human
history all of human history at this
moment in time in the United States of
America the little man has a better
chance of getting ahead in becoming
somebody than he has in any other
government situation in any other
economic system in human history
uh this is straight out of the Karl Marx
Playbook
uh this is not out of the Adam Smith
Playbook let me help you with that Karl
Marx father of Communism Adam Smith
wrote the Tome that we were all required
to read on capitalism if we took
economics
so my friend art Laffer one of the
leading economists in the world says
that if you pay people to not work
please expect them to not work
pretty deep yeah it's deep and true and
here's the thing so if if I thought with
my 40 years plus in the financial world
that this was hopeful to people
I would be for it even though I am a
staunch capitalist
just set me on fire and I burned
capitalism I mean it does I believe in
it to the core of my being
and if you don't like that that's okay
go start your own show this is mine and
so
uh uh this is what we do and so if I
honestly thought that if you were
struggling financially if you came up in
a a family in a socio-economic setting
on a lower rung of the ladder your best
shot at life of having a high quality
life was a universal income I would say
go it for it but I don't think it is as
a matter of fact my all of my experience
and all of the data we have at Ramsey
indicates that your best quality of life
is when your character
is increased with Grit
discipline calluses the ability to
overcome obstacles gives you much more
joy than the dull
hum of communism
it puts you to sleep and if the welfare
system worked people would be sprinting
out of these government-funded ghettos
into a Wonderful Life and instead
they've set up camp there generationally
it's not good for you it's not you're
you have no compassion I have more
compassion than you do if you believe in
this crap because it's not good for you
it's not good for someone so I always
think you know
so people that think capitalism doesn't
work are the ones that grew up here and
were trained by a tenured professor who
believes in uh oxy who believes in Karl
Marx more than he does Adam Smith and
they were taught by some idiot college
professor that this stuff actually works
well it works in Sweden let's just keep
in mind here Sweden the entire
population of Sweden the entire gross
domestic product output of Sweden is way
smaller than Dallas
okay so you can't really extrapolate
that type that size of an economy to the
size of an economy like ours and say
something works so that's just bonehead
asinine analysis
okay so you just that that's just crap
now
what does work is this
incentive what does work is a belief
that if I leave the cave kill something
and drag it home I get to keep it and
the government won't take it from me
that I had a young guy working for us
remember when social media first started
many years ago and we're all start we
learned this new term SEO yeah and he
was a young Tech guy and I was from
Czechoslovakia any of this fabulous
American accent but with that Slavic
accent right American he spoke English
but with that Slavic accent I wish I
could do it Hillbilly Slavic would be
awesome but I can't do it so anyway
Milan was his name and Milan left to go
get his master's degree he was 25 years
old went to go get he's he loved I love
Ramsay I love Ramsay but I'm going to go
get my Master's Degree that's my best my
best invitation it's not pretty good
yeah pretty good and he he I said how
are you going to pay for it I don't know
but I'm gonna figure it out this is
America yeah
so he goes the the the cost of the
Master's Degree for the first uh
semester was four thousand dollars he
goes to a garage sale
three days after he quit here
and the guy at the garage sale was a
Nike salesman
and he had a whole garage full
of last year's Nike's shoes samples that
he used to go to the stores to make the
sale he used to go to the vendors to
make the sales
so Milan buys the entire garage of last
year's Nikes
for 15 dollars
he said my whole back seat was full my
whole trunk was full I filled up the
passenger side love that he goes I put
them on eBay he said Dave in 48 hours I
got the money to go to school what a
country what a country
you don't get that with a universal
stupid but communism
stipend yeah uh you don't get that right
you know you go you know the number of
people nowadays going to garage sales
buying used clothing for 10 cents
selling it on eBay for a buck 60 and
making ten thousand dollars a month
doing this in mass is unbelievable the
first guy that ever made a million
dollars on eBay was buying used golf
clubs from people that gave up on their
horrible golf game polished them up
flipped them on eBay yeah you don't get
that if you're sitting on your welfare
check here's one for you I interviewed a
couple recently on my show who now
making over a million dollars a year on
their YouTube channel teaching people
how they were successful at flea market
flipping so they they were making about
300 Grand a year just on flea market
flipping then they started making videos
of how they do it and now they're making
over a million dollars that is
individualism which by the way is the
opposite of Communism Community communal
is the root word and they twist it
America works because it allows people
the freedom to be who they want to be I
know a guy that was so stupid that he
filed bankruptcy because he was so bad
at handling money and he's made millions
of dollars teaching people to live yeah
right that's right yeah
what a country oh my gosh
I can't wait for the video that people
are gonna cut up with you with this new
accent I think it's gonna be huge it's
horrible it's a horrible I wish it was
good because it was so bad it's not bad
oh you can't detect any East Tennessee
in that at all no Middle Tennessee no
Tennessee anywhere hillbilly Slavic
there leave it at that it's a whole new
it's a whole new dialect I just invented
it today I'll probably make money on
that too what a concert yeah